8. some developing news overnight a  young woman is dead this morning and a  teenage boy is hurt after a shooting in  the east valley  this happened at an apartment complex  near lake mead and hollywood  metro police tell us it started as an  argument between some people  outside an apartment and the man inside  police arrived on scene around nine  o'clock last night  and found a woman dead there with a  gunshot wound a teenager with multiple  gunshot wounds was taken to the hospital  he is now in critical condition police  plan to speak with him after he's  treated  now the man who lives in that apartment  was taken into custody  and is cooperating with the  investigation